in this video we take a look at a
mysterious sounding metric called
perplexity
you might have encountered perplexity
when reading about generative models you
can see two examples here one from the
original transformer paper attention is
all you need and the other one from the
more recent gp2 paper
perplexity is a common metric to measure
the performance of language models the
smaller its value the better the
performance but what does it actually
mean and how can we calculate it
a very common quantity in machine
learning is the likelihood
we can calculate the likelihood as the
product of each token's probability
what this means is that for each token
we use the language model to predict its
probability based on the previous tokens
in the end we multiply all probabilities
to get the likelihood
with the likelihood we can calculate
another important quantity the cross
entropy
you might have already heard about
cross-entropy when looking at loss
function
it is often used as a loss function in
classification
in language modeling we predict the next
token based on the previous token which
is also a classification task
therefore if we want to calculate the
cross-entropy of an example we can
simply pass it to the model with its
inputs as labels
the loss then corresponds to the
cross-entropy
we are now only a single operation away
from calculating the perplexity
by exponentiating the cross-entropy we
get the perplexity
so you see that the
is closely related to the loss
plugging in the previous results shows
that
this is equivalent to exponentiating the
negative average log probability of each
token
keep in mind that the loss is only a
weak proxy for a model's ability to
generate quality text and the same is
true for perplexity
for this reason one usually also
calculates more sophisticated metrics
such as blur or rouge on generative
tasks